[Música]
Produce frutos casi todo el año y
De los frutos podemos extraer esto.
compuesto que se caracterizó en
cannabis sativa llamado cannabidiol derecho
no tiene el componente que tiene un
efecto psicotropico que seria el tetra ahi
de cannabiol, thc y solo tiene la
principio nuestro primer análisis el
solo cannabidiol
[Música]
¿Cuál es el hecho de que ella está relacionada con
cannabis ella tiene el cangrejo pero
No tiene las desventajas del THC.
ella puede ser
utilizado libremente en la investigación para
¿Puedes lograr lo que nosotros?
realmente quiero ¿Cuál es el efecto real que
Este medicamento tiene varias enfermedades.
humano, eso es lo que queremos tener
distribuir a todos para que puedas
investigacion aun queda mucho por hacer
estudiar sobre ello
[Música]